[Musik]
es gibt kein zurück in eine erste
premiere für eine renn ließ bacher und
seine tochter laura als neues bühnen du
seine komiker erfahrung 33 jahre ihre
nun kann das gut gehen
was macht so ein projekt mit einer vater
tochter beziehung
davon handelt diese geschichte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
proben statt
rindlisbacher überreicht seiner tochter
den text ich begleite die beiden von nun
an bis zur premiere in zehn wochen -
wenn wir improvisieren
die urologin zum beispiel einfach nur
das leben ist einfach willst du das
[Musik]
hallo herr release bacher bitte setzen
sie sich das schöne rindlisbacher einer
der berühmtesten komiker der schweiz
den durchbruch schaffte er 19 86 mit den
schmier ins kids zusammen mit stefan
schmidt leben
[Musik]
das lied dem konto da bin ich schnell
danach knüpfte er mit edelmais an diese
erfolge an
zusammen mit sven furrer la gomera der
mitte laktoseintoleranz selber wissen
was ist laktose intoleranz kategorie zur
frage was auf uns was wir schätzen aber
gar nichts
nach dem ende von edelmais stellte man
ihm immer wieder die gleiche frage ich
mir vorstelle kaum einer vorstellen so
und das ist es auch wieder die usa auch
sie wurde einberufen wurde nicht vor
fielen und hat dort seinen ersten
interviews verschiedensten ihre tochter
auf bühne so dass ich den
atmosphärischen der augen
das heißt man so oft griff und ich ordne
der wand und das bad wurde bin ganz
konkret an dass er eigentlich sie sagte
sofort ja
laura windsbacher stand schon immer
gerne im mittelpunkt spielte als kind
und jugendliche theater immer bälle was
für edelmais brot an eine himmel
sachlich mehrere hundert knobi du bist
das möchte und so bist du sammelst und
und über das rettet oder ist das genau
proben und machen und tun und für mich
genau wie ich serviere was unter nicht
dass wir für mich krank sie es die 25
jährige kündigte ihre stelle in einem
büro denn die zeit ist knapp
[Musik]
zwei wochen später ich begleiterin
miesbach nach basel zu seinem co autor
er fährt mit dem zug gezwungenermaßen
den fahrausweis musste der komiker vor
einem jahr abgeben
er verursachte mit alkohol im blut eine
frontalkollision in der presse ein
großes thema über wochen
bin nicht sicher ob überhaupt der
moritat der forscher und unvollkommen
die biopsie und ich habe mir gesagt oder
stephanie der autofahrer also
infrastruktur eine pavk und innerhalb
ist verrät sie tun jetzt zu unserer form
von irina voigt und sagt mir dass ich
das wahrscheinlich auch weil inspiriert
ist basiert liegen sie müssen sich bei
ihnen um verwickeln wie die person die
ganze öffentlichkeit strom und das ist
ein uns andere ich wollte einfach dass
nicht nur maler laberst du hilflos
vorwoche und du legst nur was bis jetzt
passiert und weil es das ist
euro
epilepsie ist nicht die einzige
krankheit von rindlisbacher davon später
mehr
doch
dann bist du groß
[Gelächter]
carlos amstutz spiel selber theater und
führt ein restaurant
hier fallen sie eine freundin und
besprechen die bisherigen toben
seine tochter ist bei diesem treffen
nicht dabei aber ein thema
nach torhüter auch nutzen
du bist der opa zu tun bekomme die
kommunion für komikerinnen umsetzen als
komiker über hoch
das haben sie aber etwa oder es kann
also ich hatte man müsse sie dass man
sich mit dem hund
noch sieben wochen bis zur premiere
grüne rindlisbacher setzt im neuen
programm auf bewährtes auf seine
beliebtesten rollen
parallel dazu fließt viel privates ein
durchaus zugestehen mit passieren
du bist nichts ist im moment dass ich
das publikum zelebriert ausgenommen
wichtig ist dass waren tropisch nicht
dass du nicht das gefühl geschichte zum
gebet zum suchen was jetzt hund und
großartig und war und ding das macht nur
sinn wenn du meinst du sagen das war
großartig und wow noch mal so wenn du
das machst du erstarren oder xing wie
nix macht was in mir mit
ich wollte sich eine umsätze und ich
bewundere lauras mut ist humor lernbar
oder gar vererbt
[Musik]
das ist naturgegeben sich auch das
methodische unterhaltungsinhalte ich
kann das von schuster kfw kreis im
kinderhort da mehr projekte gemacht bin
jetzt fotos gesehen und war damit mit
mit witzige oder komische antwort oder
situation
es ist einfach klasse zusammenkünfte
ansagen mehr als image das man so wie es
mal anders hat sich das hat sich
ziemlich sicher ob du bist unser
dorfladen
ab sofort sind die beiden nicht mehr nur
vater und tochter sondern auch
geschäftspartner auch die werbung machen
sie selber hier suchen sie ein foto für
social media
das muss sechs wochen vor der premiere
treffen der in miesbach in luzern
ein krankenbesuch zusammen mit sony co
laura hat sich beim skifahren die bänder
gerissen sie musste operiert werden
[Musik]
das gerät richtig unter druck standen
sich schon vorher
jetzt kommt noch der unfall dazu nehmen
ob worte sagen einfach weg voller das
ganze noch warum wollte ich mal gesagt
jahre pause gemacht jetzt mach mal pause
immer harmonie und lasst mich bitte sind
für eine operation moni um ruck klares
responder nico hat ganze republik und
hat eine schöne woche müsse linke 20 und
ich bin froh wenn israel das war nicht
immer so
renés krankenakte ist lang angeborene
herzfehler epilepsie ohnmachtsanfälle
nierenkoliken herzen hirnoperationen
schlafapnoe tinnitus arthritis
und depressionen angefangen haben diese
2006 kurz vor einer premiere
das publikum bereits im saal er in der
garderobe
es hat mir richtig meinte es dampft und
moskito zog sie das ist froh dass sich
doch nur mit hut und zeit nicht einfach
so dass ich gemerkt habe gemerkt dass
alles jetzt führung das was wir dort
miteinander das ist nicht lange die
premiere sagten sie ab er nahm sich eine
auszeit auf medikamente verzichtete er
heute würde sich besser spüren er habe
gelernt mit den depressionen zu leben
den genauen grund für diese bisher nicht
was ist der richtige sein und ich werde
meine dass das beim anschnitt so sieht
das mit wie die maschine funktioniert
und man weiß immer genau was man damit
alles damit alles wichtig ist aber dass
man muss sich selber loser
man muss unseren de lausanne war
womöglich wirklich gut für ihn ist klar
in seinem leben passiert nichts ohne
grund
ich weiß dass es nicht vorm aber dunkel
ist und noch mal aber dunkeln ist das
ist mir bewusst dass ich viel erlebt wo
mir wo dafür spreche dass ich weiß dass
ich meine so zu einem raum und ist ein
grund weiß ich dass das sg-tor ist wo es
begleitet der bildungskonzept
[Musik]
seine krankheiten haben ihn und seine
familie zusammengeschweißt
der 55-jährige sagt mir die familie ist
das einzige was funktionieren muss dass
es funktioniert dass ich jetzt mal
schnell in und um und richtet
aber dann war es dann so weit war musste
die sie ohnehin die sprache ist nicht
fürs kochen zuständig sondern für den
humor mit seiner frau monika ist er seit
27 jahren verheiratet
sie sagt er sei ein stehaufmännchen
sehen allem etwas positives selbst in
seinen krankheiten
die reden des baggers ein
eingeschworenes quartett mit seiner
tochter auf der bühne zu stehen sieht
rinderspacher nicht zuletzt deshalb als
vorteil
sie sei eine enge bezugsperson als die
früheren partner
zwei wochen vor der premiere lowering
lisbach wieder ohne krücken
[Gelächter]
immer wenn ich dabei bin
das gleiche bild er zeigt vor
sie spielt nach
[Musik]
es wäre cool verbraucht haben stellt sie
hat selbst freude war jetzt eine
bestandesaufnahme die sich auf der couch
sitzen und das ganze macht auch das
sehen auch das risiko
rinderspacher hat klare vorstellungen
diese bespricht er mit co autor carlos
amstutz seine tochter hält sich zurück
ich habe das nicht und ich vertragen so
zu 100 prozent jeweils 1000 1000 aus und
so funktioniert vieles ist neu in ihrem
leben etwas ist geblieben cuttermesser
für sie fand laura innes bacher trotz
intensiver proben zeit reagieren wir
blockieren und hat mir bei den tisch ich
habe sehr strenge die texte auswendig
wirklich moment gedacht ich schaffe das
nützt das alles auswendig lernen
jetzt funktionierte einigermaßen
wahrscheinlich spielen und jetzt wieder
um werke handel hat - die gewichtung sie
daraus albracht und nutzlos wie krimis
und ich habe einfach die zeit genutzt um
lernen und nachher viel freier xxi
sie will auf die bühne und zwar nicht
einfach nur als tochter von damit hat
sie in ihrer jugend oft zu kämpfen
gehabt
dank der schau tochter von machen und
die hand hat 1000 handels und andere
schöne familienbonus in der schule und
handeln mit dem mann ist extrem mikro
[Musik]
bremen
tag der premiere in affoltern am albis
[Musik]
650 zuschauer werden erwartet
noch ist laura in diessbach ruhig
[Musik]
sauberer strom für tag sind seine
freunde mit und sagen sie uns endlich
mehr nervös sei sie nervös für die zehn
wochen proben liegen hinter den
rinderspachers eine zeit in der sie neue
seiten aneinander entdeckt haben
für ihn hat sich das klingt kurios und
dann auch jetzt hat sie aber ich kann es
noch nicht glauben was sie und und aber
das hat sich das hat sie hervorragend
braucht sie hat sie hat aber es ist aber
die punkt gesetzt bis dahin wie die
30.000 aus und das nicht von ihren
früheren deutschen bekannt
es geht los
das mikrofon gemacht haben oder
wer ein stück merkt dass man da auf der
bühne steht
immer noch keine spur von nervosität bei
laura aeschbacher ich bin überrascht wie
locker sie ist selbst als die vater
seinen auftritt verpasst
so gastiert die zuschauer denken es ein
witz
dabei ist er hinter der bühne wirklich
gestürzt das sind sehr dezimiert problem
berichtet
eher mussten text holen sein sturz wird
beide aus dem konzept
immer wieder kommt es zu kleinen
aussetzern bis zum schluss
dem publikum gefällt es trotzdem
[Applaus]
lauterbacher hat die feuertaufe us
komikern gestand der routinier hingegen
ist enttäuscht ja da wirklich blöd oder
wenn man sie auf menschen auf dem mond
auf der sonnenseite mit premiere ist es
dann soweit oder so komisch klingen
immer gewiss hat wie immer irgendwer wir
wissen über märz gab es am schluss lag
merkel hätte können
diese geschichte hat kein happy end aber
keine handys bacher ist ja ein
stehaufmännchen
[Musik]
ahu
hoch 1